There's an idea out there that 97% of
climate scientists agree that manmade
climate change is real.
I did a little digging on this.
97% and surprise,
surprise,
depending on what websites you go to and
what sources you trust.
The answer actually isn't so clear.
What is clear for sure,
however,
is that the overwhelming amount of
climate scientists,
the very experts in this field do agree
that the climate is changing and it has
something to do with what humans are
putting into our atmosphere.
Whether or not the exact number is
really 97% or 86% or 75% is largely
irrelevant.
The point is that the vast amount of
people who study this for a living
believe it to be true.
We haven't discussed a ton on climate
change since we've started the Rubin
report,
but I've said several times on the show
that since I'm not a scientist,
I have to go on what the majority of
scientists say.
Thus I accept man made climate change as
fat.
I'm basing my belief on the best
information that I have in front of me.
You don't just get to pick and choose.
When you believe in science,
it either is fact or it is not.
So if the vast amount of scientists that
are professionals in this industry
believe something to be true,
then I have to base my opinion on that
rather than just guessing or hoping or
picking the random scientists that see
the world the way I want it to be.
At the same time,
we should always be skeptical of who
funds what scientific study,
if there are political aims behind the
research,
and especially if there's money to be
made by claiming something as fact when
the truth remains more elusive.
A simple example of this of course,
is that if a tobacco company funded
studies on smoking and human health,
we'd all be a bit more leery of it then
a truly independent study done for a
purely research purposes.
So with all this in mind,
I do believe from all the people I've
talked to,
such as Dr.
Michael Mann,
the creator of the hockey stick theory
or my own science guru,
Cara Santa Maria,
as well as the information in front of
me,
that manmade climate change is real.
I also believe that the national
conversation around climate change is
mostly idiotic,
usually vacillating between people who
think we're on the brink of a
catastrophic climactic disaster and
those who hide their head in the sand to
the realities of the changing
environment.
Like most things,
and I always say this right,
the answer is probably somewhere in
between and that's where we have to
start having these important
conversations.
And my guest this week is the president
for the Center for Industrial Progress,
Alex Epstein.
The center is a nonprofit think tank,
which believes in creating a new
industrial revolution through technology
to improve the planet.
Alex's book,
the moral case for fossil fuels lays out
the argument that fossil fuels have not
only been an incredibly positive and
important piece for the advancement of
mankind,
but even now in 2016 they are still the
best source of energy for humans to make
the most of this world.
His book also tackles many of the myths
surrounding fossil fuels and even has me
challenging many of my own assumptions
of how much fossil fuels are truly
affecting the environment and if we've
demonized in energy source,
that still is a lot of great potential
to help mankind.
Now,
before I continue and before people
start freaking out,
let me stop.
Those of you who are going to say I
Ruben's a climate change denier for even
talking to this guy.
No,
that really is not the case,
but who I am is someone who is willing
to have the provocative and complex
conversation that surrounds it.
You guys know that I've made this show
about the battle of ideas and Alex is
ideas are considered basically heretical
in some elite circles.
He's had a public spat with Al Gore and
he's been subpoenaed in a lawsuit that
the Justice Department has brought
against Exxon Mobile.
Even though he himself has done nothing
wrong other than share his ideas.
In a truly free society,
we must allow all ideas to flourish
because sunlight is the best
disinfectant.
If Alex is,
ideas are bad,
the only way we can truly refute them is
by proving them to be so not by banning
the discussion altogether.
This is why the twitter band,
Milo Yiannopoulos a couple weeks ago was
so awful,
even if it was within twitter is right
to do so.
Surely Milo's ideas weren't the worst of
all the ideas on twitter,
but he had gained influence that they
couldn't control,
so they shut him down.
While Nazi sympathizers in Isis
supporters remained there freely.
You think Milo's ideas are bad?
Yeah.
Well then use your voice on social media
to call him out on it.
You think Alex is ideas are bad.
Well then write a book refuting them.
The risk we face is that banning those
who we disagree with and suing,
those who say saying we don't like will
eventually become the norm.
This is why I think the new battle in
front of us is about authoritarians
versus libertarians.
People who want to tell you how to think
versus people who want you to think on
your own.
I think you guys know which side I'm on
and if you're listening to this,
I think you're right there with me.
My guest this week is an activist and
author and president and founder of this
center for industrial progress.
Alex Epstein,
welcome to the show.
Hi.
Good to be here.
Now I have a feeling that I'm going to
be in a lot of trouble just for having
this book on the table just for putting
this book that you've written right in
between us.
People are going to be angry right off
the bat.
They're going to be,
by the end of this interview,
they'll be converts.
Yeah.
Who are going to convert people.
They'll see the method of thinking just
just makes so much sense.
Yeah.
All right,
well I'm glad that we're starting with,
uh,
that little piece of information right
there because first off,
a lot of people have recommended that I
have you on the show people that like
you and people that don't like you just
because we do conversation here.
So I've said before that my policy on
climate change is basically,
I'm not a scientist,
so I have to sort of believe what the
scientists tell me what the majority of
scientists tell me.
I mentioned that to you before in the
green room for a second and uh,
you weren't sold on that concept.
Really?
Yeah,
it has.
Traction is really bizarre.
So let's,
let's apply that to eugenics.
So let's say we're in the early 19
hundreds,
you have a lot of public declared
scientific consensus that the gene pool
is being diluted.
That we need to sterilize people.
That there's what I call global domain,
right?
Because all the dumb people are sleeping
with each other and procreating and it's
this societal catastrophe.
The gene pool is going to degrade.
And so we need the inferiors to stop
procreating.
We need to sterilize them more.
On the case of Europe,
we need to do much more dramatically
negative things to them.
So you see these scientific consensus
and you say,
oh well I had,
I'm not a scientist,
I got a,
I shouldn't obey.
So what's,
why wouldn't you do that or would you,
uh,
well it's very clear to me that uh,
we have dumbed down things significantly
cause I'm pretty sure we're going
idiocracy at this point.
Um,
but,
uh,
but all right,
so we didn't sterilize enough.
No.
So no one,
I'm gonna get into that trouble for
that.
So No,
I see your point.
And,
and that's what we're going to do here.
So,
okay.
So first off the book is called the
moral case for fossil fuels.
So let's do a little fossil fuel 101
because I was watching a couple of your
videos on youtube and you got a great
video where you're standing in New York
City and all of these,
I guess green activists are walking
through and you have a sign and it says,
I love fossil fuels.
And they're just yelling slogans at you.
Yeah.
Forgetting who's right or wrong for a
second,
like they're just yelling things.
And I think part of what you were trying
to show them was that they didn't even
know what they were saying really.
So I thought if we just define some
terms to start,
that would be good.
So what are fossil fuels?
Yes.
I think if you had asked them,
and I do this in universities,
often I'll do a poll and I'll say,
okay,
who here believes that fossil fuels are
an unnecessary evil?
Which means we can get rid of them
quickly and we should,
you know,
there this addiction,
we need to get rid of them quickly,
right?
Half the room will raise your hands.
And I say,
okay,
who believes that they're a necessary
evil?
That is,
they're really bad.
But we're stuck with them for some
amount of time.
The other half raised their hand and I
say,
who believes they're a superior good.
Like we use them because overall they're
the best for human life.
And I raised my hand and if anyone's
read my book,
they raised their hand wrong,
or at least some of them do.
Right?
And then I say,
okay,
great,
I've got a harder question.
Who here can tell me what fossil fuels
are?
Nobody raises
Saturday.
And so,
but it's a good lesson.
And people actually take the lesson
despite being a quote idiocracy and this
isn't very high level schools.
This isn't like a poker tele attack or
whatever.
They might even know more.
But I remember doing it this at
Wellesley and I think the video is
online and you can see and,
and I make the point well,
shouldn't,
isn't a precondition of having an
opinion of whether something is good or
bad isn't a precondition that we know
what it is.
Right.
So I appreciate the questions.
Yeah.
So the way,
I mean,
I can tell you how I like to define
oh yeah.
Well I think most people,
I think when they think fossil fuels,
I pictured that little cartoon in
Jurassic Park when they're explaining
how they got the,
the dinosaur DNA,
but they're showing you,
you know,
dinosaur decomposing sort of,
and then suddenly it turned to oil and
that we pull that away.
Like,
that's I think what most people in the
most simplistic way,
it's think it's something like that,
but I'm going to let you run
a little bit more.
They just think it's just,
just filth.
It's just like dirt and fill,
finish.
Just you have this dirty thing and then
you just blow it into smoke and everyone
and everything looks like China and we
really need to stop using it.
Right.
That's pretty much the visual.
Okay.
Um,
now tell me what it really,
I,
I put it this way.
Fossil fuels are a hoe and I'll,
I'll break this down,
but it's a high energy hydrocarbon
derived from ancient life.
Hey,
so it's a high energy hydrocarbon
derived from ancient life.
So hydrocarbon is one of the key
concepts.
So it's a combination primarily of
hydrogen and carbon atoms.
And we,
you can probably guess this from the
whole co2 controversy.
Basically you have different kinds of
this.
So you have natural gas,
which has a high ratio of hydrogen to
carbon.
That's why when you burn it and it
missed the Lisio too,
and then Cole has the highest ratio of
carbon to hydrogen.
That's why it emits the most CO2 when
you burn it,
to burn something as to oxidize it,
to combine it with oxygen.
So whenever you burn a hydrocarbon,
you get h two o and c o two plus
whatever else is attached to the
hydrocarbon.
It turns out that this chemical
structure stores in enormous,
enormous amount of energy.
And it also,
and also turns out that the ancient
plant life or ancient life that this
comes from,
it's different kinds of life.
It turns out there was so much of that
that we have almost unfathomable amount
of the stuff.
So I,
my best estimates that I've seen are
really dozens more than we've used in
the entire history of industrial
civilization.
So with this gives us,
from an energy perspective,
is an extremely concentrated in
plentiful source of energy that starting
about 300 years ago,
we developed the technology to harness.
Before that it was useless.
But once we developed the steam engine,
the internal combustion engine oil
refining,
modern natural gas technology,
this became by far the dominant method
of producing energy around the world.
All right,
so let's pause there for a second.
So basically this,
this former life.
So its former plant life,
animal life,
it's all the stuff they did.
Yeah.
Like playing on or it's familiar
divisions like coal.
It has,
you know,
coal is more sort of terrestrial,
other things are more underwater,
but it's an,
I mean technically it doesn't strictly
need to be from life.
And there are many theories that some of
it at least isn't it take like Saturn,
right.
Sat,
Saturn's rings are made of natural gas,
they're made of method.
So it's something that occurs in a non
biological form.
But for many reasons we think most of it
is biological and that has some
implications for how long it lasts.
Right.
Over time.
But,
but the,
the idea that we're running out of it
quickly has gone out of fashion,
uh,
recently,
just because we keep discovering new
technology.
So the,
the base amount of the material
underground is staggering and it might
be far more staggering than we think.
Yeah,
I guess I never thought of that.
So specifically because I feel like
years ago,
maybe 10 years ago,
people were always saying,
well,
we're going to run out of this,
right?
But now it seems like we're finding gas
fields all over the place,
aren't they?
Finding crazy new gas fields in the,
in the Mediterranean right now and all
over the Middle East.
Isn't that happening right now as we
speak?
Two,
two things that can happen.
One is you can find a stock of more raw
material,
which is always happening.
But the other and often more
consequential is that you can find a way
to use existing raw material that was
previously unusable.
So the whole shale energy revolution,
which people over simplify as fracking,
that's an example of that.
That's where you have,
uh,
this,
this material called shale,
which had oil and gas in it,
but it was locked in too tightly to get
out.
You have this modern combination of
technologies that unlocked it.
And just as an example in the book,
Atlas shrugged,
which has,
is,
is my favorite book.
Yeah.
Uh,
one of the heroes,
Ellis,
why discovers a method for getting oil
out of shale and 50 years later this
actually happened,
right?
What we're going to get to some
objective as him and I and ran.
But that must have been
particularly that particularly rewarding
for you,
but that show that just shows how we
know often know of the raw material,
but we can't make it a resource until we
have sufficient human ingenuity.
Right.
Uh,
now fracking,
I want to talk about it a little bit
quick and then we'll get back to this.
So fracking,
whenever someone says fracking for
stuff,
I think of Battlestar Galactica,
but then I think of,
uh,
Mr.
Burns slant oil drilling.
Do you ever see that simpsons when he,
uh,
does the slant oil drilling too,
because he creates a,
an oil refinery over here and it's
slanted so that he can do things and it
ends up going under at school and all
that.
It's the who shot Mr.
Burns episodes.
Great.
Yep.
There's another one after a while,
not just news.
Yeah,
exactly.
So they did go.
Yeah.
Oh,
so then you couldn't be happy with that
at all.
You probably really don't like Lisa
Symptom.
I would say yes.
She's probably not.
I already know the simpsons came out.
I was the exact same age as bark.
Yes.
I'm born in 1980 and it came out in 89
he was nine and I was nine.
And since I've outgrown him,
but at least I never,
I never liked even even when I was a
liberal kind of politically as a kid.
Yeah,
never forget Mr.
Burns.
How do you feel about those two words?
But he was never likable.
He was very funny.
Yeah.
So you're not forward the three eyed
fish,
you'd say.
Well that's a whole,
so,
and that's a whole interesting
distortion,
which I think reveals that the modern
environment,
what they call the environmental
movement,
which I would call the anti human or
regressive movement,
is really an equal opportunity destroyer
and attack of every practice practo form
of energy because there is no manmade co
two issue with nuclear and yet they
viciously attack it,
which I think just shows that they'll
find a reason to attack any form of
energy that actually works,
but right,
right.
That's okay.
Yeah.
So let's pause on that.
So fracking,
so I feel like people have no idea what
fracking is and I did obviously some
research before I sat down with you and
you don't,
you see all these videos of people
turning on water and water burst into
flames.
Generally that's,
I would think that that's not so great.
So sell me on fracking.
Okay.
Isn't that kind of like a funny way of
approaching like there are some pictures
of people in the water bursting on
plans,
like an odd thing.
Water racking into supplier is bad.
I mean,
this kind of goes with the issue of like
when you hear climate change,
you just sort of asked the scientists
what they think with everything we need
to look at at the full context of the
technology,
both Kay and very carefully,
both at its potential positives and its
potential negatives.
So even if someone could show me that
fracking is leading to a lot more
people's faucets on water,
which is completely bizarre,
but,
uh,
even if that were true,
I would want to know the whole context
of what's the benefit of this.
So for example,
oil and gas or the two fundamentals are
two of three fundamentals of modern
agriculture.
Uh,
oil is the only thing that powers modern
agricultural machinery,
primarily the form of diesel.
So there's,
there's just no fuel that has that kind
of versatility,
that kind of portability and natural
gas,
uh,
makes modern fertilizer.
So billions of people's lives depend on
that.
So fracking or more accurately shale
energy technology that's enabling
billions of people to live who would
otherwise starve.
So in my moral philosophy,
I take that into account.
When I think of something,
I don't just look for the negative.
So the principle is we need to look at
the full context and often attackers
just look at the negative context.
Now you do need to look at the negative
part of the context.
And when you investigate that,
I mean what you just find,
which anyone who studies water knows is
that the number one contaminant of
water,
including with methane,
which is natural gas,
is mother nature.
So if you look at the US Geological
Survey,
something like 20% of just regular water
wells are naturally contaminated.
So this is why for for centuries you
have records of people lighting their
water on fire.
So one thing that gasoline brought to
the fore is because Josh Fox was against
natural gas,
and that that brought a premium to
anyone who could show natural gas in
their water and blame it on fracking.
But that doesn't mean that there was
causation.
Now,
theoretically there could be,
but it's very rare and it's very much a
solvable problem.
Meaning,
if I turn on my water,
I'm right now in San Francisco and it
like lights on fire and it's not like
the end of the year,
it's not even a lights on fire,
right?
If I strike a match to it,
it lights on fire.
So it's not that flame is coming out of
the farm,
the whole,
you know,
the building burned down or there's
nothing like this.
So you have to have a very proactive,
uh,
attitude where you want the technologies
to be as good as possible in one
conspicuous attribute of the anti humans
is they always want the technologies
there against,
to be bad like that,
you really feel viscerally that they
want a catastrophic climate change to be
true.
And,
and I ask this question on twitter,
nobody has ever contradicted me.
How many catastrophists do you know who
would be happy if they found out they
were wrong?
Because they're gleeful.
Every storm and every,
every bad weather event that they
attribute to co2 and you know,
suv and that kind of thing.
There's a real glee.
Whereas I would,
and sometimes I'll tell them like a
counter fact,
like,
Hey,
you know that actually the rate of
people dying from climate is going way
down.
We're actually way safer.
And they immediately scream at me.
I said,
wait a second,
shouldn't you be happy at this?
That there's a possibility,
but they're not happy people in general,
but they're not,
they're not happy about the potential of
progress.
All right,
so there's a lot there.
So let's,
uh,
let's pause it.
That's a,
how did you get involved in this?
Cause I can see how passionate it is for
you and obviously you've staked out a
position that is not politically
popular.
So like when you go to this rally in New
York City,
it's,
it's not fun being yelled at people and
told you're evil and you're a sick.
People were saying,
Jerry said he's a sell out,
they don't know anything about you.
You know what I mean?
So how did you even get involved and
interested in this in the first place?
Well,
I mean,
being full and a queen popular I think
is a pretty poor goal to have.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I'm really,
so my background was I was like a total
math science kid until I was 14 or 15
years old.
Like no interest in politics,
no interest in writing.
I thought those people were the biggest
losers,
like what I do in terms of primarily
being a philosopher and talking about
things like as a kid,
I thought there was no worst thing that
you could do with your life if you were
to be good.
What you had to do was you had to be an
athlete,
a businessman,
or like a scientist slash engineer.
When I was 14 years old,
like kind of the peak of my scientific
career,
I won the national nat a Mars rover
design contest.
And so that was totally my direction.
I remember having a conversation with
some friends and they were arguing
liberal and conservative.
They said,
what are you?
I said,
what's the liberal?
What's a conservative?
You know,
which most people at 14 know that,
right?
And they started making fun of me and I
said,
you know what?
I'm tired of all you idiots.
Like yelling at each other and nothing.
I hated it because it was so illogical
and people were just yelling and there
was no common ground.
I said,
you know what?
I'm going to think logically about this,
just like I do a bad engineering.
And sort of since then I've just been
fascinated with the question of what are
the fundamental things that actually
lead human beings to success?
What are what I call now the fundamental
principles of human progress?
And I went through being a liberal
conservative,
a libertarian,
and as you mentioned,
discovering Ayn rand when I was 18 we
had a really big impact on me,
but I really cared about that issue and
it really bothered me that people
couldn't have intelligent discussions
and that there was no common a frame of
reference.
So a lot of my career,
really all my career has been a trying
to figure out what needs to progress and
be,
how to persuade other people.
So when I see the anti human movement,
as I call it,
I think that movement contradicts every
fundamental principle of progress.
I think it contradicts human
flourishing.
I think it contradicts individual
freedom.
I think it contradicts critical
thinking.
I think it contradicts our nature as
transformers of nature.
So I really hate it and I hated it since
I was 18 and I've loved ability and,
and I only got into energy like nine
years later,
but I,
I really oppose the anti human movement.
So it's,
it's,
it's about fossil fuels,
but it's about every form of making life
better.
And I think fossil fuels is one of many
things that's really good that the
Greens have misrepresented as poison us.
Right?
So we'll get to the Greens in a second.
But,
so I,
I'd imagine that a certain amount of
people watching this are going to say,
all right,
so he's into fossil fuels.
Andy's into iron rand and they're going
to say,
well,
I'm red.
It was somehow selfish.
I mean that's when I,
when I've talked to your own Brooke,
when I talked to mark Pellegrino and a
few other people that that seems to be
the main critique that it,
it,
there's a selfishness to this.
And when I had John Fugelsang,
who's a bar lefty on,
you know,
that's what he was attacking.
You got him on the week after I had your
own and it was like we did one and then,
and then we did the complete opposite.
And I think they're good.
They will try to link the objectivism
idea to,
well,
you're just want to use everything now
while you can and you're not going to
leave anything for anyone else.
Now I'm pretty sure you're going to say
that's not the case,
but I'll,
uh,
I'll leave it there.
I,
I'd be surprised if they made that
connection from what I've said so far.
So,
so what I've said so far is related time
ran in terms of thinking about things in
the full context,
which I think is a very important
principle and certainly one that I
learned a lot about,
uh,
from her,
but that that should go toward this idea
of being integrated in our thinking and
long range about our thinking.
So I,
I can't take anything I said so far as
short range,
but in terms of selfish,
I mean,
what does selfish mean?
And this is another issue where we need
clarity.
So that to me is selfish.
Means that I act from my own interest.
But I think the proper interpretation of
the moral interpretation of that is that
I do that in harmony with everyone else
doing so.
But even if I didn't,
I mean,
if the climate is actually just ruining
everyone's life right now,
that's not selfish about itself.
So there's this idea of the harmony of
human interests and that would apply
here.
So that's why we need to explore
something like co2 because if c two is
really making the world into an inferno,
uh,
whether you're an ego,
esther,
an altruist,
lots of people are going to get hurt.
Yeah.
For the record,
I don't believe the premise that I left,
but I know that that's a lot.
That's one of the critiques that I hear
a lot because I know that if you,
if you live in a way that's for
yourself,
we'll living a good life for yourself
means not destroying the environment.
Cause you have to live in the
environment.
It means helping other people in your
community because you've got to live
with these other people.
But I don't view that as selfish.
But I know that that's one of the,
one of the critiques.
So that's what I wanted to throw it out.
Hope hopefully.
But we'll see what happens.
Um,
all right,
so basically you're saying that we have
this stuff,
it's here,
it is not only good,
but it has created more good then then
pretty much anything else that in the
last 300 years we have more,
uh,
public health.
We have more ability to do things and
transformed societies and that there's
just nothing to compare to that is that
I think it's important though that it's
primarily a future looking perspective.
So I hear both the opponents and the
supporters of fossil fuels often talk
about this as if this is,
uh,
this is an issue in the past where it's
just a history lesson,
right?
Right.
Like,
oh,
fossil fuel is brought us here,
therefore we have to use them.
And then the opponents say,
sometimes I say Epstein,
Oh,
you're just showing that fossil fuels
were useful in the past,
but not useful in the president.
I think if people read my book,
and that's not at all true,
I,
it's important to understand the past
history of energy for a couple of
reasons.
Uh,
one which I talked about in chapter one
of the book,
the secret history of fossil fuels is
that all the catastrophist made today
are actually very old predictions.
There are several decades old,
they have been tested,
they've failed.
And so we have a lot of material for
analysis.
Uh,
but even more important in terms of
energy,
if we look at the relationship between
energy use and every aspect of human
life,
we see this very dramatic positive
correlation.
And what that points to is what is
energy?
So I mentioned I am and why it's
important.
So I mentioned,
you know,
fossil fuels as a potential source of
energy,
this high energy hydrocarbon.
Um,
but the fundamental behind that is what
is energy?
So energy is really our ability to use
machines to improve our lives.
And what we see is the more access to
that we have,
the better we can make everything.
And I mean,
everything,
everything.
So I go to a lot of trouble,
uh,
to show that.
So,
you know,
from agriculture I mentioned,
so I literally say the oil industry
solve world hunger and people think
that's a joke.
But it's really true
because basically we could far more and
create more for more people.
Basically you,
you know,
you and I as human beings,
we might work out,
but we're very weak,
right?
We can't,
we're not superman right now.
If we had superman,
we wouldn't need oil because superman
has real skill is not reg rescuing Lois
Lane has real skill.
Is Industrialization right off I had a
superman.
I would just say like,
you know,
get all the ore out of the minds and
like
that's his who super power is power.
For the record.
I just watched that Batman Superman
thing and I don't even know what his
skill is at this point.
That thing was such a freaking mess.
Okay.
So that's a total sidebar,
but I okay.
Okay.
So I'm going to get dumb.
See you.
You want to work on an intellectual
level.
If you need like three hours of like
dumbing your brain,
that's your mind fly a lot.
So my usual remedy is to watch the,
cause I have this temptation to go to
the theater.
So I just say I'll wait three months,
I'll watch the first five minutes and
I'll hate it.
And then I'll never,
I'll never have to deal with it but put
money on it.
So,
so,
okay.
So we have anyway,
like basically what oil allows us to do
is to be like superman.
We can multiply or any form of energy,
but if we can multiply our,
our,
the amount of energy,
the amount of power we have by a hundred
times or more,
and that enables 1% of us to be farmers
instead of nearly a hundred percent in
the past.
So it's just this amazing thing.
But one other example that just to show
you the breadth of it is medical
research.
Because often I'll say,
we'll get look at these insane
correlations between energy use and life
expectancy.
And they'll say,
oh,
that has nothing to do with energy.
It's just medical research.
And I said,
well,
how did those researchers get time to do
that research?
Because he certainly didn't mean any
time when they're on the farm.
So basically the more physical labor we
can do through machines,
the more time we can spend doing mental
labor,
including both of us have mental labor
careers,
right?
Right.
So we need to be very,
uh,
we need to be very appreciative of,
of energy.
But,
so to go back to your question,
what I'm saying about fossil fuels is
not merely they were a good source of
energy and we should sort of be grateful
and give them a gold watch or something
like that.
What I'm saying is,
if you look at the ways of generating
energy by the standard of what's cheap,
plentiful,
reliable,
and scalable to billions of people,
no industry comes close to what the
fossil fuel industry,
uh,
can do.
And so in terms of our moral
calculations for what we want to do over
the next several decades,
that has to be factored into the big
picture along with these potential
negatives that we can talk about it.
Right?
So I'm guessing that some people would
hear that and say,
okay,
if the,
even if I take all of that as crew,
why not?
At the same time,
if there is some risk related to co two
emissions and uh,
you know,
greenhouse effect and all that stuff,
why not just at this moment just start a
massive transition to green?
Well,
so we can talk about green but,
but you might make the,
it would be a stronger argument if it
were alternatives.
And then we can talk about why the
Greens are anti-nuclear an anti hydro
hydro,
which are the only decent non
[inaudible] two.
Right.
Okay.
Sorry.
So let's do that then.
So they'd hear what you said that okay,
I'll I buy all of that.
Right.
That means said if it's still putting
out some bad stuff into the atmosphere
and we're not sure what exactly what
that's going to do.
And even if we cut our emissions in the
United States that India and China are
still going through what we went through
50 years ago and they're going to keep
one of this about why not just make that
transition anyway.
So this is a couple of issues here,
but one is his thinking in the full
context means being really clear about
magnitude.
So one is what is the magnitude of
superiority of what the fossil fuel
industry is doing versus the others.
And then what is the magnitude of the
downsides?
So let's say hypothetically,
so Al Gore gave the speech in 2008.
Al Gore,
my,
my uh,
favorite person here.
Your buddy,
we'll,
we'll get to,
I'll go ahead with my buddy,
but he said we should outlaw by the year
2018 all what he calls a non renewable
sources of power.
So basically he wanted solar,
wind and some geothermal and he claimed
we could do this in he clammed.
I know of renewable sources that can
generate energy for the equivalent of
less than a dollar a gallon of gasoline.
Now I've asked what this is.
He still has not named this source,
but he was willing to outlaw all of
American energy,
right?
In order to do it.
So and at the same time he would claim
that we're decades away from 20 foot sea
level rises,
which would be a very,
very negative thing.
You know,
very,
very hard to justice.
That's kind of a one scenario of
magnitudes where fossil fuel industry
actually has no magnitude of superiority
in terms of generating energy and it has
an incredible damage,
right?
And incredible downside.
But what if it was true that say we had
a minor amount of warming and that the
fossil fuel industry was just way,
way it was generations ahead of everyone
else.
In terms of transition,
I think the implication would be,
and I think this is implication no
matter what is that you would want a
free market,
a transition.
So you'd want to look at what are other
technologies and are there any things we
can do to liberate them.
And I think the number one thing you
could observe is that the
environmentalist since the 70s have made
nuclear power drastically more
expensive.
Many times more expensive.
So instead of the cost going down time,
which is the natural progression,
as human ingenuity is applied,
the cost has gone up many fold.
Even though nuclear is provably the
safest form of power ever.
Device.
Yeah.
Wait,
let's pause there for a sec.
So they made the cost go up because they
force what you would,
I think argue are unnecessary
regulations essentially.
Um,
with everything in life you have to do,
you have to have a certain threshold.
So basically their threshold of safety
is what they would call infinite.
So let's say nuclear is a hundred times
safer than any form of power.
I don't know the exact numbers,
but that's not implausible,
right?
They'll say basically,
no,
it has to be a million times safer.
And so,
um,
you know,
at a certain point you can make anything
infinitely expensive by having an
unlimited number of employees,
you know,
unlimited amount of containment or an
unlimited amount of time,
which is perhaps the most damaging
thing.
So you have a nuclear reactor.
It used to be able to build these things
in a couple of years.
Now you can basically not build them
your chances of building them or
certainly less than one half and it
takes over 20 years.
So that kind of thing,
because in effect they've co because of
the regulations that they've helped push
through through governments,
they've called,
they've forced the price to go up
because you need more people,
you need more research,
you need more capital or capital and
mean.
If you just think about like if somebody
says,
hey dave,
I,
you know,
I needed some money and like you just
came into all this money through
patriot,
you know,
you're,
you're all,
you're really successful now.
Like help us,
help us,
help us find an answer that had to land
it.
At minimum it's going to be ready in 20
years,
but it may never be approved.
What are you going to,
are you going to do that?
I mean,
there's no way you want to touch that.
And then what happens is because of
that,
they have to get subsidies and special
loans and then the green say,
seat,
look,
your,
you can't compete on the free market.
But it's like,
you know,
bashing.
And Michael Jr.
It's like the Tonya harding approach,
right?
It's like Nancy Kerry.
See Nancy Kerrigan.
You can't,
you can't compete on the free skating
market.
No,
but you're not allowed to bash the
person's leg.
So my point is that a real alternative
energy policy is just a free market.
So that's what you get.
And you had much more of that in the
seventies then you do today.
So I think it's very revealing that
they're not for that,
but,
but my own evaluation of the negatives
of fossil fuels,
particularly with CO2,
is that they're much,
much less than people think.
And therefore I think it's a good thing
that we're continuing to expand it.
And I think it'd be very good if we
could continue to expand other things.
But whatever's competitive on the free
market,
we shouldn't force people to use junk
because that just increases the price.
But I think there's a lot of different
exciting things,
but,
but I think they're generally the
opposite of green energy,
which you raised before.
And so there's a question of why are the
Greens obsessed with what I call the
unreliables with solar?
And Wind,
they can't reliably produce electricity.
Why is that their number one focus
instead of nuclear and hydro?
I think anyone who's sympathetic to them
needs to ask that and really ask is the
issue co2 or is it something else?
Right.
So on the nuclear front,
um,
would you say the threshold?
Like,
so for example,
what happened in Japan about what was
about four years ago now,
and they've been saying that this
reactor has been leaking into the
Pacific and you know,
you hear people say,
well
now this stuff is eventually going to
make its way over to the west coast of
the United States and radiation and all
that stuff.
Would you say that,
that,
uh,
well first off,
do you agree that that is true?
Well,
this is all a threshold issue.
So the idea,
there's this idea that no amount of
radiation is safe,
but we're experiencing radiation right
now.
I'm getting some from the potassium
inside your body right now.
Right?
If you go to Colorado,
you'll get,
you'll get more radiation if you,
I mean,
I don't know how off color people can
be,
but the best,
the best go,
go,
go the best nuclear line ever from
Edward Teller,
which just a Edward Teller was this
brilliant physicist who,
who helped invent the h bomb and he,
I don't think never got a Nobel prize
because he was extremely anticommunist.
Uh,
but he,
he had this,
he was trying to explain to people that
you shouldn't be afraid of a nuclear
power plant.
It basically said if you live right next
to a nuclear power plant,
you get slightly more radiation than you
do by sleeping next to your wife.
He said,
what's the lesson from this?
We'll sleeping with one woman is safe,
but sleeping with more than one is very,
very dangerous.
So yeah,
but that is that.
But that's what you like.
People have no concept that it's all
about the threshold.
So the idea is the,
the question would be is there anything
resembling a dangerous threshold and you
don't have any deaths at all.
You don't have radiation sickness.
What you do have is scares where people
do die because of forced evacuation.
So this happened at three mile island as
well.
Nobody died.
There was no threat of death,
uh,
from a,
from radiation.
But you have these elderly populations,
you have them scared and it's because
there's this demonization and I think
there's a big parallel between the
demonization of manmade CO2 and the
demonization of manmade radiation.
And what I would argue is that the anti
human movement demonizes everything man
made and we expect it to be bad even
before we investigate that.
It's bad to expect any change of climate
to be bad before we truly investigate
it.
Okay.
So the anti human movement,
I like that phrase in general.
It just got very dystopian something
there.
I like it.
So basically it seems to me that,
that these,
there's an element to these types of
people that think that everything's
about us.
Sort of,
that I think you may be,
don't think that they think that there's
something sort of empowering in a way.
If you think that we are controlling
that through our actions,
we're controlling the environment in a
way.
It's a very,
uh,
it's really focused on you.
You know what I mean?
That by,
you know,
I live in West Hollywood where we don't
have plastic bags anymore.
And at trader Joe's,
if I have to pay 10 cents for a paper
bag,
which I usually do well,
but they prefer that you bring your own
bag.
And I always think like I,
it's nice that we're doing this and I
tried to bring my bag when I can,
but like I always think it's more like
we're just sort of doing this to sort of
feel good about ourselves really.
Because no matter what we do here,
especially on that very local level,
as I said before,
China and India are going through their
industrial revolution now they're going
to,
no matter what we do,
that makes us feel good.
They're going to keep doing all of that
stuff.
So in some ways it's sort of just,
it's like a combination of sort of lack
of science and keeping things about
yourself.
Did that,
did I get anywhere on there?
Yeah,
cause this is often the conservative
criticism,
which I think is generally wrong.
So I don't think so.
I think it's much more that I think it's
much more a hell narrative.
I think if you look at the,
the idea of a hell and what causes you
to go to hell,
I think that's much more of a parallel
because if you think of like what causes
you to go to hell,
you know,
you violate a certain commandment and
the commandment isn't,
it's not necessarily a scientific thing,
it's just that this is what was
commanded.
And if you go against it,
then there's going to be a negative
causing my gaze.
Cause earthquakes kind of thing.
Sure.
That you don't buy into,
no,
I don't know that I've ever heard it.
Well at least you know,
Pat Roberts,
it'll get every time there's an
earthquake,
you know,
power of the [inaudible] fracking.
So told us,
okay,
now this is defragging instead of the
deans out,
hypothetically plausible causal relation
to you imagine a gay fracking,
then he'd really,
I can't actually,
that would be something I can,
yeah.
Um,
okay,
so what we're going to this idea,
what's the idea that,
that,
that uh,
that it's somehow a view of it's all,
it's all about us,
but so let's,
let's look at it from a different
direction if you will.
Get Industrialization is all about us in
the sense of we are taking a planet.
And what we're saying about the planet
is this planet is imperfect.
It's not nearly safe enough in its
natural state,
and it doesn't have nearly as much stuff
that we can use,
right?
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
transform the heck out of it by using
our minds to create these machines and
then create energy that can feed these
machines and make ourselves a hundreds
of times more powerful.
And the planet is going to look
completely different because of what we
do.
So I called this human progress,
and I think this is fantastic,
but if you look at the Greens are the
anti humans,
they don't think this is fantastic.
They don't think,
oh,
it's all about us.
Isn't this so great?
What they're always worried about is the
ecology or the ecosystem or Gaia,
you know,
having some revenge on us.
But the focus is not really our power.
It's actually our stupidity.
It's the,
it's,
it's our hubris.
They think,
oh you think you can just change
everything and be okay.
You think that you can split the atom
and play God and it's going to be fine,
but it's not,
you're going to get punished.
And that's why they always have this
divine retribution.
Except it's not divine.
It's the ecology.
But no matter what happens,
every decade they have a new form in
which ecosystem is going to exact
retribution for our industrial,
since it always changes.
So there's no,
there's no change in the dynamic.
There's just a change in the specific as
the dynamic,
as each dynamic gets refuted.
Yeah.
That's really interesting.
So basically I think that they would
generally argue that someone like you is
anti-science.
Cause they would say,
okay,
all these climates,
I had to say this,
he's saying the reverse,
but what you're saying is actually bear
anti-science because yeah,
we split the atom and then they go.
But some bad shit's going to happen
because we have,
but you would say,
well,
that's what human progress is,
right?
Yeah.
Some,
some shit's going to happen and we'll
have to fee and that's,
we'll figure that out,
right?
I mean,
so that,
that really is the most scientific.
Yeah.
So I'd say,
I mean,
fundamentally to put it in [inaudible]
terms,
I think they're anti mind.
So one,
one way of looking at this,
as I mentioned that there's this idea
that manmade co two is bad.
Manmade radiation is bad,
but he,
you know,
manmade industrialization is bad.
So basically everything manmade is
considered bad.
So you know,
now at this moment in time,
plastic bags are considered less natural
than paper if you go into whole foods,
right?
It's all about natural,
local as little technology went into
this product as possible,
right?
That's what green ultimately boils down
to,
right?
The ideal.
Think about what does the ideal green
earth,
the ideal green anything is what the
world would look like if human beings
had never existed.
That is their ideal,
right?
The eye.
What's the ideal form of food?
The kind of food that we would exist if
human beings had never existed,
right?
What's the ideal amount of co two in the
atmosphere?
The amount of CO2 that would exist if
human beings had never existed?
What's the amount of radiation if human
beings never existed?
So that's,
they have this very deep premise.
So what is the manmade?
The manmade is simply the form of change
in nature that exists created by a human
mind.
That's the only difference,
right?
Change is inherent in nature.
That's why climate change is this kind
of a name term,
right?
But everything changes things.
Everything is transforming things in
nature.
But the manmade,
the only difference is that it's driven
by a mind.
So if you're anti manmade,
you're anti mind made and you're anti
mind.
So then you might ask,
why do they appeal the science all the
time?
Why do they try to take the high ground
on science?
And the answer is because science has a
lot of prestige and if you want to put
over bad ideas in volk science,
but notice they're against all the
practical products of science,
at least the core one,
the core leaders of the movement.
Well they're using them all the time
though.
What do you mean?
Well,
they're using all the things that
science has given us.
Right?
Well,
the way I think of it as this,
like would the green movement,
if it could go back in time with the
green movement,
have approved turning a patch of dirt
and trees into New York City?
What day?
What Green Greenpeace of a thumbs up to
New York City.
I guess at best it would have been a lot
slower.
No chance.
Right?
So Central Park would be allowed to
here.
We,
their philosophy would have prevented
everything that we know,
uh,
from existing,
but they are parasites on that.
And then they,
you know,
so they're,
they're hypocrites.
But this is the way that all bad ideas
work is basically the people promoting
the bad ideas want people to contradict
them to a certain amount.
Because we followed all the bad ideas.
Everyone would die,
right?
What they want is people to contradict
them so they can feed off of them.
I mean this is bred out of atlas
shrugged,
but then they can keep them guilty and
so what they want for the
industrialists,
like if you look at the oil companies or
any companies,
what they want is for the oil companies,
they don't want the oil companies not to
work.
They want the oil companies to work and
be super guilty and give them money and
tell them that they're great for being
one,
for being nothing,
for accomplishing,
nothing,
for producing nothing.
So it's basically people that very deep
resentment of productive human beings
who want to feel important and
environmentalist are anti humanism gave
them this perfect vehicle,
but if we call an anti humanism,
they're going to be a lot less confident
and there'll be fewer of them.
Yeah.
It's funny because as you're saying
that,
it makes me think of,
I've what I've been saying lately about
just pundits on television,
they've ever made anything,
they've never done anything that's
created and everything,
but they somehow know how to do
everything all the time.
You know what I mean?
They always know that healthy,
if we saved $200 billion to do this and
put this tax cut and Barbara,
and it's like,
well,
you've never done anything.
You just keep saying things,
but you've never actually created.
It's a lot easier to do that then
actually create,
I think psychologically,
I haven't studied this,
but this is plausible to me.
I've heard different studies that
there's just a deep and fewer
inferiority complex among intellectuals
who just don't really feel productive in
a certain way.
Now,
I don't experience this myself.
I mean,
I think it's useful to learn how to do
certain kinds of physical things,
but I also am an intellectual who
worships the physical creators.
So I give them justice and I know,
you know,
who's buttering my bread.
Uh,
so to speak.
Right?
I mean,
I know,
I know when I talked to somebody from
industry that they are making possible
my way of life.
And for instance the universities or the
opposite because modern universities,
I mean we have way too many people going
to college I think.
But however many people we would like to
go to college is way more than the
number that would go to college if we
were non industrialized.
And yet the universities have incredible
contempt for industry.
And I think it's just a very disturbing
thing that you have all these talking
heads,
all these mindless students often and
they have no appreciation.
So let's say even the fossil fuel
companies,
we're screwing up way more than I think.
I mean,
I don't even put it though.
I think they're doing a great job in
general,
but you should still have a lot of
appreciation for what they're
accomplishing.
And,
and you should still realize that you're
paying them to do that.
So we have this idea where the non
producers can demand this impossible
perfection of the producers and look
down on them even though you're doing
nothing,
which is like the Teddy Roosevelt Teddy
Roosevelt quote about the man in the
arena.
Like Teddy Roosevelt is really into
sports and stuff.
So he talks about how the man in the
arena is the one who's admirable,
even though everyone else side.
He said it's not the critic who counts.
There's right.
That's important.
Right?
So what are you watching?
A basketball game.
But they always know every though it's
just like
going on with Lebron.
I mean,
come on.
Yeah,
I think that it's,
I can do that.
So all that said,
when,
when something like the Exxon Valdez
happens or the BP oil spill in the Gulf
and when these things happen,
now I get it.
Nothing's,
nothing's a perfect system.
So these things are gonna happen.
But for someone like you,
when you see the BP oil spill and you
see all of the birds and the auditors
and all this stuff covered in all this
oil and know that,
you know,
I just remember those days where they
had a online,
you could just watch that,
that a pipe,
that burst pipe just spewing all this
stuff into the ocean.
How do you feel about that?
Well,
it's a negative,
but there's an end.
There's always this issue of magnitude.
And I always look,
particularly if I know that we have a
tendency to be biased against one
industry,
I'm always suspicious of these.
Like why is this?
Why is the oil spill considered the
worst thing in the world?
So to me,
11 people died on that.
That was the,
that was the tragedy of an mean 11
there's thing exploded,
right?
So the guy who people
are extinguished,
right?
I mean they never get to do anything
again in their families.
You know,
wives are just,
there's,
I mean that's the thing.
If you look at what I mean oil is to use
a green term,
like an organic substance.
I mean,
it's just ancient kind of life and lots
of things in the ocean like it.
And then certain kinds of animals don't
like it.
So,
and of course the only point to the
bird,
you know,
so if it's on a bird,
it'll choke the bird.
And that's not,
you know,
that's not something that I relish.
But in terms of the things that happened
to human beings,
an oil spill is pretty low on the list.
So what I think it shows is this idea
again of the manmade.
If we accidentally put oil somewhere,
it's bad.
But you know,
there are two,
Exxon Valdez is coming out of the Gulf
of Mexico naturally all the time in the
form of oil seeps.
So if you look at the tar sands,
that's just one giant oil spill,
a by nature in Canada.
So I think we always have to watch out
for this bias against the manmade bias
against the human.
I think the sort of better examples are,
um,
I mean it was solar and wind.
There's an example I talk about in the
book where when you're mining for those
elements for the kinds of metals that
you use and in solar panels and,
and particularly windmills,
uh,
people die a lot because they happen in
places like China and they're in very
dangerous situations because you're in,
you're dealing with legitimately
threatening amounts of radioactivity and
nobody cares about that.
So I always look at what are the actual
threats and non threats of every form of
energy and what I try to do it,
and I think chapter two of the book is
go through them in a pretty,
uh,
fairway cause it's not like I started
out being pro fossil fuels.
It's something that I came to.
I mean,
as a kid I thought some like solar and
then I,
I was never anti-nuclear really.
All the simpsons scared me a little bit,
but I just kind of always figured,
oh well solar's the greatest thing.
But then once I looked at the equation,
I thought,
well,
it's not nearly and why are the Enviros
so focused on this when they could be
focused on nuclear?
But I mean,
so I think the kind of most,
you know,
the things that are more of a concern,
like can you say smog in China?
Right.
Because to me that's,
that's something where that's clearly a
very unpleasant and in some cases
unhealthy thing,
right?
Literally affecting someone's life on
that day to day basis.
To me that's much more of a concern than
an oil spill.
So then what in a case like that,
that you're,
you're acknowledging that it's a
legitimate concern.
What do you do?
I get,
I guess you've now find industry that
cleans it up,
right?
I mean that's,
that's the next level in the colonies.
Milan.
I,
I
like to,
I like to look back in time and just
think,
if I like to look at the 18 hundreds
it's just sort of a reference point
because if you look at that time,
they had much worse smog than China does
today.
I mean,
what much worse?
And so the question is,
did they have a green movement that said
this is ruining everything?
Like we hate it.
No,
they had that as a letter that I
mentioned,
which says basically they,
they,
they're worried about running out of
coal because they don't really
understand the geology of it and how
much of it there is.
And they say,
you know,
basically this would be like losing a
limb.
It would be that bad.
And again,
this is something that's has all the
smoke.
And so from our perspective,
we think,
oh,
this is so bad,
it's so dirty.
But why do they value it so much?
Why don't even focus on that?
Because the value of energy to empower
them to improve their lives,
to actually be fed,
to actually be warm,
that takes precedence over everything
else.
And so then the point is that whenever
you're defining a threshold of pollution
that you need to legislate regarding,
you need to have the context of what's
overall beneficial for human life and
what your alternatives are.
Now,
fortunately today we don't have to
accept that threshold of Smog and smoke,
right?
Because we have all sorts of
alternatives and we have technology.
So I think in the case of China,
it's,
it's a midway case where they could,
because it's a dictatorship,
because they don't respect individual
rights in many ways.
What they did is they built a lot of
coal plants,
but it's not primarily coal plants is
actually other things that you use cold.
They're just burning it in a very open
way.
But they did this very haphazardly
because they had this national goal of
industrialization without focusing on
the purpose of industrialization,
which is human flourishing.
So I think if China and India had much
better governments that focus on
individual rights,
they would have much less.
But that doesn't,
that's not to say they would have the
same standards that we do because they
don't have the same level of wealth that
we do.
So it's contextual based on the state of
economic and technological development.
And one,
one great philosopher in front of mine,
while I was writing the book,
he gave me this great analogy about you
could,
you could say the same thing about human
health.
So there's a point that I think is
really important that people are afraid
of coal plants.
You know what,
I'm afraid of you.
I'm afraid of humans because humans are
way dirtier.
Then our machines,
which again shows that were against
manmade things because we're afraid of
machine waste,
but not human waste,
human waste.
And particularly,
you know,
the air we breathe,
breathe out is biological and biological
as much more dangerous than
nonbiological.
So if I get sick,
it's going to be from someone in this
room and you know that's how you're
going to get sick and die most likely.
So why do we allow ourselves this kind
of pollution?
Right?
Well,
because at the moment it's not
technologically preventable in any
economic way,
but it's much more dangerous than what
the gold plants are doing.
I mean,
I haven't seen anything to contradict
that,
but in the future,
let's say,
he said,
well,
what if you had buildings where you had
affordable technology that could filter
all these diseases?
Then you might say,
you know,
you're required to do this right?
Or you're required to disclose if your
building doesn't have this.
So what?
What is considered a dangerous thing in
the future could be considered a normal
thing in the present.
Right.
Okay.
So I want to spend basically the rest of
the time we have here discussing the
real underlying issue to all of this,
which is very much related to everything
I do on this show about free speech and
the role of government and all this
stuff.
So you mentioned Al Gore before and uh,
you know,
one of my things with Al Gore is that,
he's,
I saw the movie an inconvenient truth.
I really liked it at that w when did
that come out?
About 2006.
Okay.
Really,
really liked it at the time I thought
it,
we woke up some things in me that maybe
I hadn't thought of before.
Fast.
Fast forward to what?
About three years ago,
Al Gore decided to sell current TV to
the government of Qatar so they could
put allergists ear on here and the
government card does tons of fun stuff
with fossil fuels.
So,
and he basically created the producers.
He created a failed network and s and
profited on it for $500 million.
I mean he did the producers he used,
he leveraged the first one to point this
out.
I've been saying it for a while.
I don't know that anyone,
but he's basically a max be all stock.
Like he created the pretty,
he created a failed network and then
ultimately he walked away with a ton of
money and the reason he was able to
create the network was cause he was the
vice president had all the connections
and telecoms and all that stuff.
It's not easy to get on cable channels
and all that,
but basically we created a shitty
product that he walked away with a ton
of money and at the same time he took a
massive check from the government of
Qatar who does a ton obviously with
fossil fuels that he's always railing
against.
So I'm putting that out there that I
have no,
I suspect something's not quite right
with what this guy is doing in the
scheme of this thing.
But can you lay out a perhaps more
enlightened case than that?
He's just doing the producers because I
sensed that
what?
Well,
so basically the,
the federal government right now it
sounds like is starting to attack think
tanks.
Right.
But they're attacking think tanks that
do the very work that you do.
Now I would argue that because I believe
in free speech than a think tank should
be allowed to think.
And I don't like governmental control
over thought,
even if I completely disagreed with
whatever the premise of the think tank
was knowing.
Um,
but this is happening right now.
So first of all,
I guess,
how is that directly related to Al Gore?
Somehow when the,
cause he's not part of the government
anymore.
Hmm.
Right.
But he is a figurehead.
I mean he,
I don't even know what the legality of
this,
but when they announced this,
so I guess we should give people a
little bit more context there.
So what's happened is over the years,
what I call the climate catastrophists
and I just don't want to quickly,
we haven't talked much about the,
the climate issue specifically.
I just,
yeah,
just in terms of my view and other
people's view,
there's not this idea of climate
believers in climate deniers.
It's a really a dumb old kind of
alternative.
But there are different assessments of
the magnitude of the warming influence
of co two.
So we put x amount of co two in the
atmosphere.
So let's say 130 parts per million or
0.013%
since the beginning of the industrial
revolution.
And the question is how much does that
affect climate in terms of primarily
warming then anything that comes warming
and then how much can it,
it'd be anticipated to affect in the
future as we put another point.
Oh 1% another point.
Oh 1%.
And so basically we could go into the
details,
but we don't have time.
Uh,
some people think that that's a very
mild and manageable warming.
Uh,
and they point to things like the amount
of co two in the atmosphere in terms of
the geology of the globe is at almost
record lows.
Temperatures are at almost record lows.
So in terms of the history of the
planet,
when we had 20 times more co two it was
a very fertile time.
Two is plant food.
So what they argue is that CO2 and I
argue is a,
has a warming effect,
but it's what's called a decelerating or
logarithmic effect.
Now that's actually not controversial,
but then the other side says,
well,
even though it's a decelerating effect
in the lab and the atmosphere,
there are these other dynamics that make
it into this xl accelerating or very
dramatic thing.
And that's why we can expect runaway
warming.
Pause there real quick.
So the decelerating meaning that at some
point,
even though you're putting this stuff
out,
eventually start sort of simulating
itself,
it's just like a function like
diminishing returns.
When you think about like when you press
the pedal on your gas,
right?
So at a certain point,
every little push it goes faster to like
55 and after the go slow,
right?
Otherwise you'd just take off like a
rocket and could go forever.
So it's,
it's,
it's the same kind of thing.
Every molecule of co two warms less than
the last.
So this is an uncontroversial scientific
fact,
which by the way,
is part of why you need to learn a
little bit about the science.
You just have to ask people.
The key thing is what's demonstrated and
what's speculated.
So this phenomenon of CO2 has
demonstrated,
but again,
there's this other set of theories
which,
uh,
I think are very speculative,
certainly not proven,
but have to do with catastrophic
warming.
But other people are allowed to have
those theories.
I don't want to suppress the theories.
I think upon examination there very
dubious and whatever they are,
you have to look at them in the context
of the benefits of fossil fuels to,
you always have to look at the big
picture no matter what.
But basically what I call the,
so I'm calling them the catastrophists.
So it's not,
that's why I call them the
catastrophists.
So it's not a nonbeliever,
I just believe in mild.
Okay.
So that,
that's just the distinction.
So basically what the catastrophist have
had is what they consider failure.
Now I consider them enormously
successful on their own terms because I
think they've indoctrinated,
you know,
the whole world.
Uh,
and hadn't passed a lot of bad policies,
but on their terms,
they have not shut down the fossil fuel
industry.
I mean,
they want to shut down 80% of it in the
next 30 years,
the next 35 years.
They're not accomplishing that.
They tried to pass cap and trade.
So what they've done over the past
several years,
their basic premises,
well the reason we haven't done this
because people are idiots and there must
be some villain who's causing this.
So of course,
who is the villain?
Big Oil,
who's allegedly forcing us to buy oil
when in fact we basically ask them to
produce the old,
right.
So,
but so what they did,
they have this thing called the
divestment movement,
which is basically sell all of your oil
stock and that'll demonize them and
everyone will hate them and then they'll
vote against him.
So mad hasn't worked so well so far.
So now what they have is,
is the government actually prosecuting,
I would argue persecuting the company.
So different attorney to General.
So,
you know,
each state has an attorney general and
what they're doing,
they're going after the biggest and
allegedly baddest Exxon Mobil and the
attorney generals are saying basically,
Exxon,
you over the years have not expressed
what we believe are the proper climate
catastrophists views.
And in fact you have funded people who
don't have those views.
So if you just said that,
you'd think,
oh,
well you're allowed to do that,
right?
This is America.
You're free.
But what they've done is they've called
it fraud,
right?
They said you've defrauded,
but for many reasons it's not fraud.
And the basic thing is for it to be
fraud,
you have to misrepresent specific facts.
Fraud is not expect expressing a wrong
opinion or even a wrong opinion that
serves you.
Companies do that all the time.
It's misrepresenting specific facts that
you have specific access to right now.
The biggest tension really.
Well,
but it,
but,
it's a specific thing like you have to
misrepresent.
So let's say Exxon selling a kind of a
certain kind of gasoline,
then they misrepresent the contents of
that.
That's fraud.
But they didn't misrepresent the fact
that gasoline admits CO2 when you burn
it.
Everybody knows that.
Right?
And the experts on that were mostly
government scientist.
So Exxon didn't,
you have an ability to defrauded anyone.
It had an ability to express opinions
and to fund people or be affiliated with
people,
express different opinions.
So what happened then is the government
subpoenaed Exxon,
different people subpoenaed Exxon,
but they also started going after think
tanks that they suspected might be
connected with Exxon.
And several wednesdays ago they came
after me,
or at least I was named in a subpoena,
which means the government has any right
at once to records of any emails between
anyone at my company and anyone at
Exxon.
So that,
and my views is a complete violation of
my rights.
And in my case,
it's interesting because I don't run a
nonprofit.
I don't run a company that accepts
donations are a for profit company,
sell books.
I sell lectures,
right?
So there's no plausibility that Exxon is
sort of paying me to do something and
they went after me.
So why did they go after me?
Because I have a prominent book called
the moral case for fossil fuels.
So what they're saying to me is,
and what they're saying to me is,
Alex,
because you expressed an opinion we
disagree with,
we are going to invade your life and
people are afraid of that.
So how are they actually coming at like
what are they trying to do to you as a
for profit business?
So I get what they can try to do with,
with Exxon,
right?
They can ultimately legislate things
that would allow Exxon to not do
business the way it seems to be
legislating their prosecutor prosecuting
people in jail.
Right.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so I understand that.
But at what can they do to you as well?
I guess it's the same thing.
Competitive of Enterprise Institute.
Uh,
at least for a while they were going
after that organization.
So they're going after that organization
as a party to it because of Exxon is
committing fraud than the people who
help.
It can be considered a party to that
fraud.
But you see that the core issue,
I just think my case brings out that the
core issue is expressing an opinion that
the government disagrees with.
So,
uh,
I mean it just goes against just a,
you know,
a fundamental principle of progress is
speech because we can't make progress
without having the freedom to discuss
ideas and debate ideas and have
intellectual clarity.
And so for this to happen is,
is really horrible.
And I think I'm in a position where,
because I was,
I was only named on the Sabine,
I wasn't subpoenaed now,
I couldn't be in the future.
But right now I'm,
I have a lot of latitude to speak out.
I have 100% ownership of my company.
I don't know if shareholders,
I don't have donors,
so I'm not accountable to anybody.
So I have an ability to,
to be very vocal about this issue now
and I'm taking advantage of it,
hopefully to preempt them from doing
something more in the future.
I saw that they did some attack recently
and I wasn't named in it.
I don't know if that was a coincidence,
but I defend,
I just wanted to make clear by defend
Exxon's right to express its opinion.
I actually think it's been when it's
given way more money to climate
catastrophist,
uh,
than it has to,
I would say climate thinkers,
which I would call myself A.
I think in general they've been way too
sympathetic.
They just came out in favor of a tax on
co two.
They've been promoting that.
So I think their policies are wrong in
the wrong direction,
but they can say anything they want in
certain,
given too much away.
I know out of guilt sort of or whatever.
What prompts you to anti humanist?
100 million guilted them into doing more
than you would argue they should have
done because you guys obviously none.
I mean they should have done none,
but particularly given the balance of
funding already.
I mean you're talking orders of
magnitude different amounts of funding
for the catastrophists versus any kind
of advocate of fossil fuels,
but they gave $100 million to Stanford's
climate program,
$100 million for every calculation I've
seen.
That's a way more than they've given to
anyone else.
So this,
you know,
these think tanks,
these nonprofits,
I mean,
I really admire a lot of them.
I met a lot of the people,
I think they were really sincere and
they have a hell of a time getting
funding from any of these,
these companies.
I think the company should give them,
I don't need money.
I have a different kind of business,
but I think they should be giving a lot
more money to fund opposition research.
And that's a fundamental thing in a free
society and a one key function of
industry is to,
if the industry is being attacked,
it should fund opposition,
right?
I mean it's,
it's even like,
um,
now,
so if you even take the tobacco
industry,
the tobacco should,
should fund research.
What it shouldn't do is misrepresent and
a lie about the researcher fund fraud.
But,
um,
you know,
if somebody,
let's say somebody was exaggerated,
I don't know anything about tobacco
really,
I never spoke,
but like let's say somebody was
exaggerating by a factor of four,
the damages of tobacco and you wanted to
do research,
um,
that would be legitimate.
So what my point is in a free society,
you should be able to talk about
anything you want the eye.
This isn't a marginal case.
This is a completely normal thing for
people to be able to talk about.
And it's really scary that,
that,
that people thinks is,
okay,
this is on the democratic proposed
platform.
All hurt,
Hillary Clinton has to do with sign and
this is part of their platform that,
and,
and what kind of stupid platform is it
to tell the executive branch to go out
the pro form source.
We legislative.
So it's just bizarre.
But they're telling the executive branch
to go after specific companies.
That's their platform.
Yeah.
That's a whole other topic.
What's going on with politics or
aggressive?
It's,
it's the regressives.
Yeah.
Wow.
I almost got through a show without
saying regressives there you go.
But so that,
I guess what's happening here is that
there's some,
there's sort of a bigger cultural thing
here,
so you were talking about this and
through the lens of fossil fuels and all
that stuff,
but there's just a sort of bigger thing,
which is what I've really made this show
about,
which is just about free speech and
that's why I keep talking about it so
much because I think people don't
realize,
again,
regardless of what you think about
climate change and fossil fuels and
everything else that you've said here,
that the,
that the real linchpin here is the free
speech stuff.
And I keep saying that.
I don't fear it,
the government coming lately,
I fear that we're taking away from
ourselves.
But you're laying out a pretty good case
on the government side.
So that's even,
yeah,
I mean I imagine you're talking about
like these,
these comfort zones and safe spaces and
the trigger warning
and self censorship that we're doing
really well.
I mean,
I graduated Duke in 2002 and it wasn't,
I mean it was bad then,
but it wasn't,
I mean I'm actually almost got kicked
out of Duke for yelling at a guest
environmentalist speaker,
but in general there weren't even those
terms said that this idea of thought
control the,
I think there's a relationship even even
sort of private thought control that's
not directly coercive,
but where you basically make everybody
afraid to say anything about any
controversial topic.
My guess is that makes people very
comfortable with government thought
control.
Oh,
that's interesting.
That's interesting.
All right,
so,
uh,
we got to wrap up,
but what would be,
give me your like one minute sort of if
you wanted people that have heard this
and that.
I've said,
all right,
I never bought into any of this stuff,
but I,
you know,
I like some of this with this guy.
He said,
what's the one minute push that you can
give them to explore this a little bit
more beyond buying my book,
which I'm going to talk about when I say
goodbye.
Yes,
it's an issue.
I usually bring up more.
So I want,
I'll,
I'll say this,
whenever we look at any issue in life,
we're,
we are implicitly or explicitly saying
this is good because I define good this
way.
We always have an implicit definition of
good,
whether we're talking about climate or
fossil fuels or free speech or whatever.
And so my,
what I call my standard of value is
always I want to maximize human
flourishing.
And I think in our culture today,
the standard of value or were taught
particularly with environmental issues,
is we want to minimize human impact on
the planet.
So I want people to think whenever they
run into these issues,
ask,
ask themselves,
is this thinker on the premise of
maximum human flourishing or are they on
the premise of minimum human impact?
And I think when you look at things,
whether it's organic food or GMO or
climate,
you'll see a lot of that minimum impact
is the ideal.
And I think that completely contradicts
maximizing human wellbeing.
So if you want to maximize flourishing,
you want to maximize,
you want to minimize negative impacts,
but you want to maximize positive
impacts.
I think that's a great filter to look at
life through.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's a perfect closing,
but I should mention that you said to me
right before we started that one of my
former guests,
Michael Mann,
who is a climate scientist I think at
Penn State Penn state or am I right?
Yeah.
Uh,
that he uh,
he's blocked you on twitter,
which I guess goes to a little bit of
just how contentious this whole thing is
because you on musk is black to you too.
I mean w w w what was interesting about
Michael Mann,
I'd say when,
when watch Michael man speak,
I encourage anyone to watch any of his
lectures.
I haven't seen your interview,
but I've seen his lectures.
We'll get the precision or non precision
about the issue of what is demonstrated
versus what is speculated.
Because what they tend to do is they'll
say something trivial like co two warms,
which everyone agrees with and it'll
jump into therefore it's catastrophic.
So just look at,
is Michael Mann really respecting your
mind?
Is He really explaining things with the
degree of precision that would be
necessary for you to really understand
the topic?
I'm not,
I'm not asking you to take a position.
I'm just saying that people should think
about that.
And one indication is how they deal with
debate.
Now people can,
I don't block people,
other people that they can have their
policy.
But Michael Mann wrote a post that said,
Alex Epstein is the Koch Brothers attack
dog,
which wouldn't be a negative thing in my
view,
but it was bizarre.
I mean,
it's not true and nobody's funding me at
all.
Um,
and he just made it up.
He just completely made it up.
The idea what he didn't engage my
argument and then I said something to
the effect of this is a lie.
What is your evidence?
And then he blocked you.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's what you see there is that when
people,
so there are two types of,
I think having the moral high ground.
One is when you have a real confidence
and that's when you're willing to
explain your views to people.
And the others where you have a certain
societal status where it's not really
earned,
but it's considered you dominate the
politically correct version.
Uh,
uh,
you have the political correctness at
this point in time in society.
And when people have that kind of pseudo
moral authority,
they do all sorts of irrational things.
So when somebody acts like they have the
moral high ground,
I think seeing if they're really a
debater or whether they just want to
dictate to you that's or,
or ignore you,
that's a really good test.
I think it's a good,
you know,
one of the reasons why people really
value this show is,
you know,
you're not an unconfident gile though.
You know,
you're interviewing people,
but it's,
you know,
there's a certain confidence and being
willing to discuss things with anyone.
And there's a certain,
it's very reveleigh Tori,
when people are not willing to discuss
things and their number one talking
point is there's nothing to discuss.
Right.
Well,
I always find it funny.
It's that I never felt,
I've never in my life felt the need to
be right all the time.
And everyone I feel in the public space
always wants to prove how right they
are.
So I'm completely fine having this
conversation and maybe I would look back
now on my interview with Michael Mann
and sort of look at through,
through a bit of a lens of what you've
just said there and maybe a,
if I have him on again where I would
push him on some of those things.
All right,
well that's the conversation I want to
have and that's why we did it.
So you can get Alex's book,
the moral case for fossil fuels and
check out industrial progress.com
the link for the book is right down
below.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll do it again next week.